digamos que tengo el número 0.17 como
puedo nombrar a este número aquí lo dije
de una manera pero que otras maneras hay
de que yo me pueda referir a este número
expresar lo en términos de décimas o
centésimas u otros lugares decimales y
como siempre traten de pausar el vídeo y
reflexionen sobre esto por su cuenta hay
un par de formas en las que podemos
referirnos a este número o nombrarlo 1
es decir 0.17 otro es decir bueno tengo
un 1 en el lugar de las décimas así que
aquí tengo una décima
y pues aquí tengo un 7 en el lugar de
las centésimas
y aquí está el 7 en el lugar de las
centésimas así que puedo decir que tengo
una décima y siete centésimas esta es
una manera de referirnos a este número
otra forma de nombrarlo es decir todo
este número pero en términos de
centésimas bueno una décima cuarta
centésima son pues son diez centésimas
así que podemos decir en lugar de una
décima que tenemos diez centésimas y
bueno yo lo escribo así pero realmente
muy pocas personas se escribirían este
número así diez centésimas y siete
centésimas
y ahora puedo sumar estas centésimas
aquí tengo 10 centésimas aquí tengo 7
centésimas 10 + 7 17 centésimas así que
podemos escribir esto como 17 centésimas
y para tener la intuición de por qué
llamamos a estos 17 centésimas en lugar
de decir una décima y siete centésimas
vamos a calcular centésimas aquí hay una
centésima dos centésimas y vamos a irnos
directamente hacia las nueve centésimas
y aquí cuál sería la siguiente como
puedo decir yo diez centésimas pues
vamos a escribirlo de esta manera 10
centésimas es lo mismo que una décima
así que si estoy contando mediante
centésimas la siguiente de estas 10
centésimas pero como habíamos mencionado
10 centésimas es lo mismo que una décima
es lo mismo que decir que diez unidades
es igual a una decena espero que esto
nos haya confundido vamos a seguir
contando 11 centésimas 12 centésimas 13
centésimas 14 centésimas 15 centésimas
16 centésimas y 17 centésimas así que yo
espero que esto los ayude a intuir por
qué llamamos a esto en lugar de decirle
0.17 con una décima y siete centésimas
podemos llamar a esto diecisiete
centésimas ya una vez que comprendimos
esto vamos a realizar un par de ejemplos
en los que haremos lo contrario digamos
que nos dan el nombre de un número
usando palabras y nosotros tenemos que
escribirlo como decimal entonces aquí
nos dicen cuatro decenas y tres
centésimas así que estas cuatro decenas
de acá y de hecho permítanme colocar
algunos lugares aquí este va a ser el
lugar de las decenas
y aquí está el lugar de las unidades
aquí tenemos nuestro punto decimal le
sigue el lugar de las décimas
y luego el lugar de las centésimas
así que aquí tenemos cuatro decenas no
décimas son decenas cero unidades aquí
está el punto decimal y no nos dicen que
tengamos alguna décima así que son cero
décimas y nos dicen que hay tres
centésimas así que cuatro decenas que es
lo mismo que 43 centésimas entonces
tenemos 40.03 hagamos otro ejemplo nos
dicen 24 centésimas siguiendo la lógica
del ejemplo anterior podemos escribirlo
así como 0.09 o lo que es lo mismo 9
centésimas si queremos una centésima más
pues serán 10 centésimas
si queremos 24 centésimas pues
escribimos aquí el 24 y si ustedes me
dicen oye espérate esto parece en dos
décimas y cuatro centésimas pues si
tienen razón pero recuerden que podemos
reescribir esto como
décimas
cuatro centésimas
pero no se les olvide que una décima es
igual a diez centésimas así que dos
décimas es lo mismo que veinte
centésimas veinte centésimas y cuatro
centésimas y por supuesto veinte
centésimas más cuatro centésimas son 24
centésimas y espero que esto les haya
ayudado a comprender el ejemplo